my son wakes up at 5:00 depending on the
day five or six and if I do a spot at
the Comedy Store and I get home by say
midnight 12:30 and he's up at 5:00 yeah
that's the beef hey listen I got to tell
you my my daughter sleeps like a bear so
really she gets up around 7:30 8:00
lucky man so what still sleeping is not
an issue for my wife and I and we hear a
lot of parents say oh you know getting
up in this in any I think my baby knock
on wood 12 hours solids I'm not he's not
a peep so I might be like you you're not
never seen you hyped or stressed in my
life what stresses you out making too
much stress knows what I do I buy my
last bit less [ __ ] in my teeth that's
some seaweed before I came oh no I don't
get overly excited you're right I don't
get overly excited and I don't get too
overly stressed out it's just even yeah
I get excited when I'm around people
like my wife or my parents I'll show a
lot of excitement if something nice
happens to me but like my manager agents
you know they'll call with good news I'm
like on it's great and then they're like
hey do you care kind of at the top of
the mountain right now so after a while
it's all gravy I mean after a while but
maybe it's like you be like cuz with
Brian he'll get some news I'll get super
excited for him or all you get news all
you per excited he's like no no no no
chill man you and Seinfield talk about
Porsches at all he's like mr. Porsche
yeah he's he's so into the porch like I
don't know what's under the hood I'm not
that guy
he's his master's degree and yeah he
knows like in 1956 they came out with
too much I don't know any of that I just
drove a damn thing you know I don't know
a lot about anything I just in detail I
don't get detailed but you went on not
really but you went on comedians in cars
getting coffee right yeah oh boy yeah
yeah we became fast friends over the
last three years and it's a here's a guy
who's
through all of that the stevie showed
the touring and the whole thing and any
time when I have like a question about
the business and that's kind so yep
Seinfeld I've Rogen and Brian yeah yeah
you have these guys in your career you
know by the way when he did the when he
ventured off and did his own podcast
like he's got another one right jealous
I mean do I feel betrayed again of
course I'm not jealous I'm not you know
I'm not jealous you know I have its
royalty yes 10% worth anything I do and
it should be 20% but I don't give up I
get drunk on the rooftop and I do ice
cream I made you competing with other
people in comparing I don't know how to
do that I mean I understand it's very
human adieu I understand that but it's
it's a bad idea no I get you let me talk
I'm the guest there are words that I was
it Antebellum did I use the word priests
pre-civil war no there was a woman
sitting next to me on the plane and she
she looked at the guy and she said
across the aisle she goes do you know
what this word means
and I went I couldn't help it and I went
and the word was pogrom and I happen to
have known what pogrom means because it
doesn't matter but I I went into a long
explanation of what the word is it's
actually a Yiddish word that is what the
Jews used for when the Russians when
when the non-jews would come in and
basically kill you or blame you for
something it was a pogrom they would
periodically a czar with neck inflation
is bad the crops suck plagues let's
blame the Jews and the Jews were kept in
what they were called pails these like
ghettos and they just send a bunch of
hugging you know Russians in they
basically raised their kills everybody
here [ __ ] them up or whatever it was
called it for Grom wow I'm out okay no
I'm glad I don't know that's already
saying this if somebody asked you next
week would a pogrom
did you even listen to that zero zero
bro and she did the same thing Isis this
clean I was staring at this I swear to
god she did the same thing and I realize
it was him I went this is too long
explanation and I and I spoke too soon
she doesn't care I don't care anymore
and nobody else is gonna care about this
story and I just weird time like this
how about making afraid reach out to us
we're talking about forever and I was
thinking about that I'm not getting
nettles in my feud be [ __ ] with your
psoriasis yeah I can't I can't be in the
Sun I can't be gone for 21 days
no I mean do you think we'd last nope
you don't think you and I would last you
know you can meet with like a nature
expert beforehand of teachers like fire
and how come each other's mouths like so
I you know what I I don't want to be in
a desert and I don't know if I would be
like Nicaragua I prefer a desert Oh over
jungle hold on listen he bugs in the
jungle let's just cover the desert real
quick no water hot hot during the day -
well he just so hot do it right no water
in waters you mean what is the most
important part of the holidays so water
there's lots of no plants vegetation so
there's no bed or sleep on sad night
freezing freezing the jungle were shaded
bunch of leaves and stuff we make cool
costumes together I've been played
Jumanji into the jungle been in the
jungle
what they don't tell you about a young
gal is it you get weird funguses and you
get lots of stings and your ass box is
wide open
oh did you get stings you get all kinds
of [ __ ] poisonous snakes everywhere in
our ass holes are just wide open like
pug dogs I don't walk around my [ __ ]
wide open I don't we're gonna be
tracking I don't want my foot naked is
not the gay game ever even tried cocaine
have you never know drugs over here yeah
really a little bit of weed I've done
I'm not a drug guy either I'm not I
don't like cocaine before I've done you
know Jordan comes to those work I've
eaten mushrooms before but not a lot I'm
not a drug guy and I spoke a little bit
of William to
Morrison and I've done I've done DMT
okay I've done DMT yes you have but that
doesn't count
does that count it's a psychedelic but
does drug that's a natural though yeah
like I've done we didn't EMT that's it
yeah
I've said no to cocaine a lot cuz I've
been around it but I just don't it's
like I got to wake up I don't have time
I actually don't like the way it makes
me I don't like I don't like uppers yeah
I I've done it you know handful of times
we're also not type guys I don't need
drugs or alcohol to have a good time
around my parents or to go out and feel
horrible I'm good
alright I'm a water I didn't like the
way cocaine made me made me feel and
behave if there's a mound of cocaine and
a large cheese pizza and like glitter
you can only have one I would choose
that cheese pizza all God did nobody did
a lot of cocaine and then things got
better by the way
mmm everyone like in holiday sugary
always gone down down down hill on their
acting career and everything else I mean
the ones that I know of yeah I'm sure
there's ones we don't we don't know if
we're that might be doing well yeah okay
yeah oh there's a lot I know you guys
watching I know we know I know
whoo hi love the boogers I know
high-functioning artists who've done
incredible things and they are they love
cocaine
who's that guy from Saving Private Ryan
that was super good ironies know the UH
he doesn't look like he's a regular
soldiers oh he was in heat too
yes that guy Tom Sizemore yeah he was
playing so so amazing but then see
Michael Caine we had the same age it
wasn't just cocaine okay Tom Sizemore
guy I know a little something called
that that'll get you that's not gonna
get you and you can't do that math you
lose team and he really did lose
everything and he was he was amazing
just really attack with him actually
about this it would seem he said she's
in really good movies yd movies Bheema
well so so there's only age so my my
agent was like Hollywood's waiting for
him to get clean cuz everybody he's on
horrible right now but they all want him
so tell